Liam Fox weren't fancy a great deal more
of this sort of thing thank you but the
defense secretary knows he's brought
much of this scrutiny on himself thanks
to the fraud handling of his
relationship with a close friend Adam
wearily and House Fox supporters were
out in force can I tell the Secretary of
State that he has our full support that
when asked to explain his involvement
with Sri Lanka the defense secretary
noted his critics weren't in short
supply either mr. speaker I'm delighted
to do that and especially in front of so
many new and interested members in
defence the name Fox knows he's fighting
for his career and having to show some
humility I accept that I should not have
had a meeting with a potential
commercial supplier without an official
being present this was entirely my fault
and I take full responsibility for it
even now the controversy boils down to a
handful of key questions why did Adam
we're at he meet the defense secretary
at the Ministry of Defence 22 times over
a 16-month period despite the fact he
had no government role or national
security clearance why did he carry
business cards with the House of Commons
logo describing himself as an advisor to
the right honourable Liam Fox MP
something he was not and why did he meet
with dr. Fox on a total of 18 trips
abroad including a number of official
visits to Dubai and Sri Lanka where mo D
officials were not present the Prime
Minister is seeing his own agenda today
with a speech on immigration blown out
of the water by the whole saga he seems
willing to put up with it for the time
being clearly there were areas where the
personal the business had become the
person the political had become too
intertwined and he regretted that he was
sorry for that he wants to answer these
questions he wants to draw a line under
it he wants to get on with his job he
has my support as he does that clearly
it takes time sometimes to to answer all
these questions and to satisfy that
people that the right thing
is being done I'm prepared to take that
time measures are now being taken to
provide greater distance between Liam
Fox and his former best man mr. Huerta
will not make private visits to the MOV
in future will not attend international
conferences where I'm pleasant and will
not meet socially abroad but I am an
official business but the opposition
fear the current investigation won't
address wider questions of ministerial
propriety looking at the ministerial
Claude it is clear that on sections 5.2
seven point one seven point two seven
point three seven point four and on
seven point five the Secretary of State
has driven a Cochin bosses through the
rules the businessmen involved in the
most controversial meeting in Dubai says
Adam were--it II who arranged things
presented himself as a key man in the
Fox team without doubt he presented
himself as an advisor to dr. Fox his
corpse it as such and standing next to
dr. Fox he would assume he's an adviser
to dr. Fox and he's employed by the
Ministry of Defence I mean there would
be no reason to assume anything else
Liam Fox now steals himself for a
lengthy investigation so far there has
been a regular flow of new revelations
for his sake they need to stop now Joey
Jones Sky News Westminster